[Musique]
vous êtes sur france 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir madagascar
frapper à nouveau par un quatrième
cyclone en un mois plus de trente mille
personnes ont été déplacées dans six
régions nous retrouvons notre
correspondante sur place
trois ans après que devient le irak en
ce 22 février jour anniversaire du
soulèvement pacifique et populaire
algérien qui avait conduit à la chute du
président abdelaziz bouteflika analyse à
suivre d'asni abidi politologue algérien
spécialiste du monde arabe
on vous parlera dans ce journal aussi de
sirène en libye une cité antique de 2000
ans qui a survécu à la guerre au chaos
mais qui aujourd'hui est menacée par la
négligence de l'état laissé à l'abandon
et les victimes de pillages et de
dégradations les scientifiques plaide
pour que des moyens soient fournis pour
restaurer ce site archéologique inscrite
au patrimoine mondial de l'unesco
la tempête m nati a frappé madagascar
après anna du mac os puis bac 6 rails la
grande île a de nouveau été frappé plus
de trente mille personnes ont été
déplacées dans six régions d'importants
dégâts sont à prévoir alors que
certaines localités se remettent à peine
du passage du dernier cyclone le récit
de notre correspondante gaël morgien
ce qu'il est intéressant de noter c'est
que la trajectoire du cyclone et mme
dati est quasiment la même que celle du
cyclone bâtira qui a lourdement frappé
madagascar il ya un peu plus de deux
semaines à la différence que le cyclone
et mme dati est un peu moins violent
mais sa zone d'influencé est très vaste
ce qui va occasionner des glissements de
terrain et des inondations généralisée
dans toute la zone d' influence selon
les prévisionnistes malgache il y a
également un fort risque de marées de
tempête c'est à dire que les eaux vont
monter avec des vagues déferlantes entre
6 et 14 mètres de haut par endroits ce
qui pourrait submerger certaines
localités de la côte est donc le sort
s'acharne sur le littoral malgache je
rappelle que la ville de mananjary et la
commune de moussy val qui ont été
presque entièrement détruite par le
cyclone bâti rails aujourd'hui les
humanitaires sont toujours au chevet des
populations sinistrées les plus modestes
n'ont pas les moyens d'acheter des
matériaux pour reconstruire leurs
maisons les bâtiments publics n'ont
toujours pas été réparés ou réhabilités
donc tout est très très lent le temps
est comme figé puisque la ville de
mananjary ressemble à une ville de
lendemains de cyclone l'accès à la
nourriture et à l'eau potable est
toujours difficile et dépend de l'aide
humanitaire et tout cela fragilise les
populations et occasionne une
augmentation du nombre de cas de
diarrhée ou de kovy de 19 par exemple
est malheureusement l'arrivée du cyclone
et mme natty sera un nouveau coup dur
pour les populations
il ya un an l'ambassadeur italien rdc le
cas attanasio son garde du corps
vittorio la kova la covaci et le
chauffeur congolais qui les accompagnent
et mustapha milambo été tués par des
hommes armés lors d'une attaque de leur
convoi dans le nord à gobet les
circonstances de cette embuscade reste
opaque jusqu'à ce jour la famille de
mustapha milambo déplore que l' enquête
patine et elle a tenu à lui rendre
hommage ce mardi à goma justin cabinda
bal ce matin avec ma
famille a au petit frère même pas ça
comme un candidat passe comme non bah
c'est un fait lacombe est l'un des
schémas qui est gênant c'est que seydina
il est quasi totalité aux clichés maman
le coi à tunica qui est patente à dieu
pour ce qu'il a les assassinats bataille
promet toujours des enquêtes
malheureusement les enquêtes qui
nous faisant confiance à des attaques on
espère que cette fois ci
les oc avec l'implication de la
communauté internationale
espérons que la lumière s'éteint
ça sera donné par rapport aux
circonstances exactes de
bilan a été revu à la hausse sur
l'explosion survenue dans une mine
artisanale au burkina faso 63 morts et
plus de 70 blessés selon le procureur
qui annonce en outre l'arrestation d'un
suspect ce dernier risque des poursuites
pour homicide involontaire
mais la cause exacte de l'explosion n'a
pas encore été déterminée on passe au
mali est la déclaration de l'expert des
nations unies à lui une teen ce dernier
a noté une amélioration tangible dans le
domaine sécuritaire mais il note un
climat délétère et un recul de la
liberté d'expression alioune tine a
également mis en garde contre une bombe
sociale qui se profile à l'horizon lundi
le parlement nommés par les militaires a
entériné que la période de transition
pourrait durer jusqu'à cinq ans un délai
jugé inacceptable par la cedeao son
médiateur goodluck johnatan doit
d'ailleurs s'y rendre ce jeudi
il ya trois ans jour pour jour naissait
dans les rues d'alger un mouvement
pacifique de contestation populaire qui
va conduire à la chute du président
bouteflika un président symbole d'un
pouvoir autoritaire à la tête du pays
depuis 20 ans trois ans plus tard quel
bilan tirer du miracle nous avons posé
la question à hasni abidi politologue
algérien spécialiste du monde arabe il
est directeur du centre d'études de
recherche sur le monde arabe et
méditerranéen à genève voici sa réponse
c'est un bilan qui est très important il
va marquer l'histoire récente de
l'algérie pour la première fois nous
avons assisté à une mobilisation
populaire très importante plusieurs
générations ont rejoint ce mouvement
appelé leur fera qu une mobilisation
sociale d'abord pacifique mais aussi qui
a montré un niveau très élevé de
maturité politique et qui est l'idée
finalement qu'à demander le cas exigés
et le départ de bouteflika à la fin de
ce cinquième mandat évidemment cette
exigence a réussi à fédérer tous les
algériens de derrière ce chirac il a
poussé la situation militaire l'armée à
prendre position et a demandé le départ
de bouteflika rien que ça c'est à dire
le départ de bouteflika qui avaient tous
les soutiens et bien sûr s'ajoute aussi
à une certaine mobilisation très
importante montre finalement que le
crack est un événement politique majeur
dans l'histoire de l'algérie mais alors
monsieur habib sy s'est toujours c'est
tout de même étonnant qu'un tel
mouvement vous l'avez rappelé aussi
puissant n'ai pas pu engendrer deux
leaders politiques forts capables de
capitaliser sur cette révolte est aussi
tout simplement de changer la classe
politique algérienne
ce mouvement il avait malheureusement
une vie courte parce que il a été
rattrapé par cette crise sanitaire les
animateurs de racler les marcheurs de
manière générale avait bien sûr vais
juste et
préférait plutôt faire cette pause
malheureusement le pouvoir n'a pas fait
de pause en matière d'arrestation et ce
pouvoir a encouru finalement à à des
méthodes répressives plus importante que
celle qui avait prévalu sous bouteflika
il n'avait pas ses vrais produits des
leaders c'est une force et une faiblesse
c'est une force parce qu'on sait très
bien que tous les leaders ou tout tête
qui dépasse finalement
aller d'être arrêté par le pouvoir et
c'est pourquoi sans avoir de leader sans
avoir dé direction collégiale le lac à
continuer et toute femme à exercer une
pression et une influence importante à
tel point qu'il est devenu le seul
contre pouvoir en algérie mais c'est
vrai vous avez raison sont aussi leader
en ce cas là tu n'a pas réussi à
traduire cette mobilisation sociale ca
des grandes revendications à il de mode
politique bien structurée
mais c'est légal vainqueur de la coupe
d'afrique des nations premiers au
classement fifa sur le continent a enfin
un stade aux normes internationales et
il a été inauguré dans la liesse
populaire à diamniadio à une trentaine
de kilomètres de la capitale il a été
baptisé abdoulaye wade en l'honneur
l'ancien président la république écoutez
le récit de notre correspondant et le
mend a
pas moins de cinq 4000 personnes ont
assisté à la cérémonie d'inauguration de
ce stade qui va porter le nom de l'as et
président de la république du sénégal
abdoulaye wade une inauguration en
grande pompe présidée par le président
macky sall avec la présence de plusieurs
chefs d'état dont le président turc
recep tayyip erdogan mais également à
des présidents africains comme à paul
kagamé ou encore georges weah il faut
également noter la présence du président
de la fifa et du président de la
confédération africaine de football
ce stade d'une capacité de 50 mille
places a été construit en deux ans d'un
coût avoisinant les 150 milliards de
francs cfa une infrastructure sportive
qui ravit à les sénégalais toujours dans
l'euphorie de la victoire du sénégal à
la coupe d'afrique des nations je vous
propose de les écouter paumé magnifique
magnifique au lieu de m'en parler nous
avons examiné stade comme ça et
aujourd'hui vraiment c'est une fierté de
l'afrique dommage tout ça va nous jouer
des poings de grandes portes pour
l'organisation de grands événements
parce que ça a vraiment c'est quelque
chose d'exceptionnel en afrique instable
joie et de soulagement on n'envoie pas
le stade va accueillir son premier gros
évènement dans un moins de 29 mars
sénégal va accueillir l'egypte pour le
match retour des barrages pour la
qualification à la coupe du monde 2022
une revanche de la dernière finale de la
coupe d'afrique des nations
la cité antique de sirène a survécu à la
révolte libyenne au conflit au chaos
mais elle est aujourd'hui menacée par la
négligence de l'état laissé sans
surveillance elle fait l'objet de
nombreux pillages et de dégradations les
archéologues plaide aujourd'hui pour que
l'état mette les moyens pour restaurer
ce site archéologique lots renversés
cheikh
sur les bords de la méditerranée au
nord-est de la libye se dresse la cité
antique de sirène
construite il ya plus de 2000 ans par
des colons grecs ces ruines sont
inscrits au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco mais à part ce petit groupe de
touristes le site est complètement
désert
franchement c'est un endroit magnifique
ça me fait du bien d'être là mais le
site a clairement été négligé
ça pourrait être une attraction
touristique majeure
à l'image de nombreux sites
archéologiques en libye la cité de
sirène a été abandonné par l'état
ces murs sont recouverts de tags et ses
colonnes délabré n'ont pas été restaurée
depuis des années de nombreux artefacts
ont également été pillés et trafics et
vers l'étranger pour l'archéologue et
chercheurs fathi al sahili cette
situation est le résultat d'années de
négligence de la part des autorités
libyennes
nous n'avons pas de police ni de guides
touristiques
personne ne protège les monuments
aujourd'hui j'ai perdu espoir
les antiquités son trafic et les terres
sont divisés et vendus il n'y a pas de
musée ni à bengazi ni à sa page
embourbé dans la guerre la libye
n'arrive plus à protéger ses richesses
mais chercheurs archéologues reste
optimiste avec un peu de volonté et de
moyens la cité antique de sirène
pourrait devenir une attraction
touristique mondiale
et c'est ainsi que nous refermons ce
journal l'afrique merci à tous ceux qui
nous ont suivis c'est en particulier
ceux de sirène à goma en passant par
manas quarts et rester avec nous car
l'actualité continue sur france 24